[Music]  Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie are single  for the first time after a decade  together but don't think they are  returning to the dating scene just yet  despite recent reports a source tells ET  Brad is not dating but is spending time  out with friends our source adds the  family is getting along and is Brad's  sole focus right now meanwhile ET has  also learned that Angelina is not  currently dating either and has not  dated anyone since the split the pair's  six kids are her main priority at this  time Brad took a bit of a step back from  the spotlight after he and Angelina  separated a source previously told et  Brad has more time now he has been in  touch with most of his friends  throughout this ordeal